uh shoe's off
what this is your house
i'm just running mmm come on you gotta
buy
you always bring a backpack into bars or
what it's my stuff
i'm here for the weekend
in this jacket
andrew sammy
emma what the hell is going on wait what
hell is here
is that yes it's my wife
your sister is
my brother's wife emma i thought you
weren't supposed to come till tomorrow
well i did
come mark jansen vp regional sales i
work with andrew says you're uh
obviously amazing oh cool i've yeah i've
i heard about you too
yeah are you okay yeah no i'm um
i'm shooting for par no no i mean you
like look really really oh my god
oh my god mark mark did he just faint
sure you have to be somewhere sammy no
no
i'll stick around
[Music]
[Applause]
people came over to party so all right
then we're gonna leave
oh you're gonna go
you should drive safe
[Music]
are you peeing i am yo andrew right my
dog
we'll see you out there matt it's mark
take care matt
cake blows
and bro tell me is it weird that we're
siblings but we hooked up with another
pair of siblings
why'd you say that yeah why would you
say that
you